Bachelorette Jojo finds her true love
Aaron Rodgers estranged brother Jordan
all is right in the world or is it I
cannot believe that Nancy O'Dell who is
obsessed with this show is on vacation
Samantha Harris here filling in Nancy
has been waiting for the safe even
premiere yeah when we were with Jojo and
Jordan this morning after the final rose
and after we saw him pop the question
but here's our question in tonight's top
story is the Bachelorette fairytale fate
or faked the fourth people are going to
ask was this breaked ring ring how is it
that you guys had this all planned
before that you knew each other
beforehand where it comes from
no I never never met him never saw him
until that moment he stepped out of the
limo
hello hello I didn't watch the show I
didn't watch her season so I didn't I
did not know anything about it I didn't
know anything about her
Jordan I love you Jordan may have found
love with Jojo but his relationship with
his older brother quarterback Aaron
Rodgers remains estranged Jojo has yet
to meet him and today this gift was
going viral that's Aaron watching his
iPad and the joke is that he's reacting
to Jordan's Bachelorette win Family
Matters are sensitive and private and of
course I knew what I signed up for it's
been a post-show frenzy the couple hit
Kimmel where Jordan posted his first
pick with Jojo then they jetted to New
York for GMA and this morning with us
what's next I'm gonna be working with
the SPN and SEC network as a college
football analyst this year
I saw my real estate company I'm still
doing it and we just got a house
together in Dallas and he has a backpack
right after this I'm gonna be normal
people do you think you'll go down the
TV row and televise the wedding like
everybody else has or we haven't even
got that far that's not out of the pit
was it's everyone enjoyed our love story
and shared it with us so I could see
that being an option
I'm sure and last question Luke chase or
Robbie who do you guys think will be the
best next Bachelor I'm so torn between
this because America loves Luke I know
it realized that when I sent him home I
was like oh my gosh people I mean that
he's amazing so I totally get it but I
also think Chase would be a really great
victim Robby is a great guy also but I
really think that people love think
people fell in love with Chase he opened
up a lot more to us again
you're both great above do awesome all
right no but notice that they did not
mention Chad at all as a contender but
they did have a message for him and we
played it for him this morning that is
coming up